and now in this country President Biden
campaigns for Democrats today in
Pennsylvania it's one of the few places
where candidates actually want his
support the latest CBS News polling
shows that control of the Senate remains
a toss-up today in the race in
Pennsylvania could decide it
Ouija Zhang is at the White House with
more on that part of the story weisha
good morning
good morning to you Gail and good
morning to everybody so President Biden
right now cannot rely on his popularity
to win over votes for Democrats next
month his approval rating remains stuck
at 40 percent so instead of headlining
those Lively campaign rallies that
presidents typically do he is focusing
on his accomplishments
families are hurting you've heard me say
it before but I get it from gas prices
to new jobs and abortion this week
President Biden is going all in on those
issues when asked Wednesday about his
Focus going into the election he said
there are multiple issues at play just
hoping to clarify for midterm voters top
domestic issues inflation or abortion
all important unlike you there's no one
thing today the president is heading to
Pittsburgh to Tout The billions of
dollars he signed into law for
rebuilding the nation's infrastructure
he will revisit the site of a massive
bridge collapse
which he toured back in January on the
day the disaster unfolded with
Pennsylvania lieutenant governor and
Democratic U.S Senate candidate John
fetterman this evening the two will meet
again in Philadelphia for a fundraiser
Republican Challenger Dr Mehmet Oz wants
fetterman to stay link to the president
too blaming inflation on both of them on
the issue of inflation John Federman
does not believe Joe Biden spent enough
money Oz has also questioned his
opponent's Health after he suffered a
stroke in May I genuinely hope that
there was not a doctor in your life
making fun of your circumstances
fetterman released a letter from his
doctor Wednesday that says he is
recovering well with no work
restrictions but occasionally there are
words he will miss due to lingering
auditory issues
fetterman is one of the only Democrats
fully embracing President Biden's
support in fact this month several
high-profile candidates are holding
events but it's not President Biden who
will be stumping by their side its
former president Obama Gail
all right we should thank you very much